hey guys and welcome to my 1299 flipping
guide I mean my one 12 uh 2.47 mil
flipping guide uh what this is going to
be is just a quick snapshot of the
different stages of flipping all the way
from zero GP all the way to your max
cash stack uh now I'm not going to go
super in depth into specific items you
should do but more just categories and
when you should start flipping those
categories like for say when you have 5
mil what types of items you should be
flipping then and then when you have 100
Mil Etc so hope you guys enjoy and let's
get started so before I get started I
would just like to state that of course
this is just my opinion unlike training
a skill uh where there is a pretty set
path that is the most efficient way to
do it uh flipping will not have that
path so while this is my opinion this is
the way I would do it and I think it's
best it's not necessarily going to work
for everyone or be necessarily even the
best way to do it anyway with that out
of the way let's get started so to start
off you're not going to have a lot of
money uh what I would recommend from
clearly you don't want to really start
at 1 GP unless you're doing it for fun
of course and I do I would recommend it
it is fun uh but once you have um I
would say maybe 100K you could start
flipping some really cheap clue scroll
items so easy medium and hard clue
Scrolls have uh items that you can snipe
for cheap so these will be items like uh
elegant skirts um uh armor cloaks uh I
just flipped the CER B the other day
just like random stuff like that uh it's
not going to trade very often it's going
to take a while but honestly your time
is better spent putting in these offers
attempting to snipe something for a
cheap price and getting a really good
margin on it cuz with 100K you're not
going to be able to get much by flipping
like say you're flipping plaqu or
something uh who the [__] would flip
flax uh how about to say death runes
you'd be able to buy like what 300 death
runes you might make 2 or 3K profit it's
you're worthless and no point anyway uh
so I'd recommend
um easy medium and hard clue Scrolls
until you're at about 1 mil from there I
would still heavily recommend just
sticking to well it doesn't have to be
clue scroll items but I find they do
tend to have the big biggest margin for
the price uh so Elites and Masters will
have some really good items in it uh so
items like uh the darkness Set uh
ornament kits stuff like that uh that
you can still get for a reasonably cheap
price and sell for a good margin even
though one mil does seem like a lot of
cash uh still not really enough to do uh
high volume flips like flipping seeds
potions stuff like that uh you're going
to need a bit more cash to begin with so
I'd recommend just moving up to the
elite and master clue scroll items uh
cuz they do tend to work out pretty well
for me so another recommendation uh for
this amount of cash would be potion
decanting now I will leave a link in the
video description uh for how to do this
but basically you're just going to be
taking uh three dose potions and
decanting them into four dose potions I
would recommend doing this with super
attacks strengths defense uh super
energies work pretty well but um I
wouldn't really do PA of potions they a
bit too expensive but anyway really good
profits to be made from decanting
potions and uh if you did want to do a
high volume flip doing some cheap ones
like runes ammunitions like Rune arrows
or Adam and arrows or maybe cheap darts
uh would work pretty well as well as
cheap food like lobsters uh you're going
to be able to do some flips but I
personally don't find these to work very
well uh because you're not really
getting a very good return on these
since they trade so much uh you're only
going to get 10 20K maybe maybe more 30
40 sometimes but uh not really worth
your time but is can be fun so now we're
on to the 5 mil to 25 mil category and
now what I'm recommending here is what
I'm calling mid high volume items so
items like seeds uh darts planks all
work really well items like between 2
and 10K that have a high trading limit
or items like um seeds that uh have a
low trading limit of 200 uh and they are
more expensive but it kind of is limited
by that so they tend to have a really
good margin uh regardless so next up
once you've gotten past the 25 mil Mark
uh that opens up a couple extra
categories I would recommend uh so items
like third age cheap third age items uh
like say the thir age robe amulet or
range legs uh can work pretty well and
you can get some really good margins on
these items they're a bit slow but I've
gotten 5 or 600k pretty consistently on
a couple of these items on top of that I
would start doing some expensive high
volume items now these are really good
so items like U magic logs battle stabs
and dragon bones will all work really
well and the reason I really like uh
these expensive high volume flips is you
can really right away see uh an
excellent profits say like the battle
stabs you could do a f minute flip that
could net you 300K uh it I mean it's
expensive it could be 60 70 mil to
actually buy all the battle stabs but um
definitely worth it uh so once you get
to the 100 Mil to 500 mil Mark uh you
could think of doing some Investments uh
now most people do this by paying
attention to updates uh this is a really
good one I find updates are a lot more
consistent uh to actually get a
profitable Flip or investment in uh
where the streams can be very
unpredictable a lot of times items will
get hyped up for nothing and then crash
right down again uh so it's a lot easier
to get burned for that but still doable
uh you can also just pay attention to
General uh pricing Trends uh which can
work as well the reason I wouldn't
really recommend this before 100 Mil uh
is because you don't really want to
invest all your money into uh one item
because that's kind of putting all your
eggs in one basket and before 100 Mil
you don't really have enough money to
make a substantial investment into an
item as well as have money left over uh
to flip with on top of that once you get
to around the 100 Mil cash T I would
recommend and doing some cheaper raid
items so items like the D buw work uh
Twisted buckler you could do uh Dragon
Sword Dragon Harpoon I mean you could do
some more expensive items like the Kwan
but again you don't really want to
invest all your money into one item uh
for the earlier stated reasons but yeah
thins ball work Twisted buckler uh some
of the cheaper raid items under 30 40
mil uh could do pretty nicely all right
and now between 500 mil and Max cash uh
you got guys probably wouldn't need any
recommendations at this point but um you
can chose some of the more expensive
raid items like the Twisted bow if
you're feeling brave uh or some of the
ancestral equipment uh of course you
could do the third age long sword if you
wanted but realistically you're going to
just keep to doing some of the already
mentioned items or already mentioned
categories because these Twisted bows uh
third age long swords they're risky and
not everyone wants to do that all right
guys I hope you enjoyed my one
to Max cash stack I keep wanting to say
1 to 99 uh but anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed I know it wasn't super in- depth
on the cat or the specific items but I
hope you guys enjoyed the overview and
maybe give you some motivation to get uh
flipping again get your money higher and
eventually you can actually well anyone
get hit Max cash ATT I don't really
think um if you just keep at it the
amount of skill on Flipping is there
there but a lot of it's just persistent
and consistently just putting in items
to flip all right hope you guys enjoyed
and I'll see you guys in the next video
[Music]